uh here with more the founder of outkick
we have clay travis with us along with
the author of the big new book battle
for the american mind uprooting a
century of miseducation fox and friends
weekend co-host pete hexa first
congratulations on the book amazon.com
we'll throw it up on hannity.com
um but
if you look at this one issue
i understand why democrats are doing
what they're doing there are all these
other issues they don't want to talk
about so roe v wade if it does go away
uh the states will decide what the laws
will be
and i doubt
if if any states will totally completely
outlaw abortion i don't think that's
going to happen and if they did people
would have access in neighboring states
new york california or anywhere else
they wanted to go is that correct
correct
this is the far left extremist ship is
sinking with joe biden at the helm they
know it on every issue you just laid out
sean they believe that this criminal
leak of a potential draft of a supreme
court decision is their life raft and
they are clinging to it and screaming
from the hilltops they just declared
that you
me i don't want to speak for clay but i
presume clay and everyone else who who
has supported the policies of donald
trump or believed in america first
is the most extreme movement in american
history
they have pegged and maxed their
rhetorical response and as you pointed
out from the bitter clingers of barack
obama to the basket of deplorables to
hillary clinton that type of demagoguery
doesn't work politically as well and and
to hear kamala harris say how dare you
all i think that does is make voters say
where's that passion on any other single
issue and it only reminds
voters in the electorate that the only
thing they care about is aborting
babies or children as joe biden admitted
as opposed to addressing things that are
crushing the american people right now
so it shows the left for the extremists
that they are and i don't think it'll be
effective but it's tragic here we are
demonizing the president one side of the
political aisle effectively is
terrorists i think what this is going to
come down to look um i'm pro-life clay i
do make exceptions some of my friends
disagree with me uh rape incest the
mother's life there are other people
that i know in my life that i respect
their opinion they say they're
pro-choice but they always will say that
abortion should be rare and it should be
first trimester
what has happened with the democratic
party in in many of these blue states i
listed them last night they actually
allow abortion up to the moment of birth
and then of course ralph northam's
comments post birth abortion which is
murder
um and i think they've gone so hardcore
radical on this issue they're the ones
out of touch because 67 percent of
americans um think it should be legal
but there should be restrictions like
for example mississippi saying 15 weeks
max what are your thoughts
i agree with the vast majority of the
american public and with a lot of what
you just said sean and notice what's
going on here the democrat party which
has spent basically a year and a half
all of joe biden's administration
arguing that democracy is under siege is
now
outraged that nine unelected justices
are poised to say hey let's let 50
states decide what the law should be so
that all of your state representatives
all of your state senators and your
governors of both political parties can
have a robust debate and figure out the
appropriate policy in every state so
that thanks to federalism we can have 50
state laboratories look i went to law
school sean anybody who reads the roe v
wade opinion almost unanimously
regardless of their political opinions
if you take away what the result is
agrees that it's an awful opinion you
quoted ruth bader ginsburg saying as
much and she certainly agrees that
abortion should be legal right what is
happening here is we are holding
democracy accountable for 49 years we
haven't been able to have a real debate
sean i think this is significant it's
often about whether or not the supreme
court should be legalizing abortion in
some way now it's about whether your
individual state and whether you want to
support people on either side of the
aisle that's what should be happening
here this is democracy flourishing this
is judicial restraint this is the
opposite of judicial activism this is a
democracy in action you would think the
democrats remember sean wasn't too long
ago in the supreme court they stood up
and said every single american has to
get a coven shot or you lose your job
now they don't want for democracy to
work on this issue uh it doesn't add up
all right clay always good to see you
thank you pete by the way congrats on
the new book we'll have you on about
that soon as well uh amazon.com thank
people's new book hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else